a few months ago i asked my followers on
twitter what was the most important
experiment ever done
[Music]
more than a dozen people replied almost
instantly the famous madame wu parody
violation experiment and today i'm going
to tell you why i agree with them come
along on this ride into the impossible
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
you may be familiar with the concept of
parity the state or condition of being
equal regarding status or pay today
sadly we're going to talk about one
famous scientist failure to achieve
parity with her male counterparts more
on that later one of the most perplexing
concepts in quantum mechanics is
heisenberg's uncertainty principle the
fact that the more you know about one
property of a chunk of matter the less
you know about a corresponding property
a complementary property such as
position and momentum imagine you're in
a dark room you are told that a
ping-pong ball is rolling around on the
floor you can find it and know exactly
where it is but you lose all notion of
what is its velocity
those two properties position and
momentum are complementary in
particle physics as well there's another
property called spin which is a
consequence of angular momentum of
subatomic particles and it's impossible
to know simultaneously the spin along
two different axes that are orthogonal
to one another at the same time we know
a lot about motion in the universe and
one of the most common features of
motion is rotation the rotation of
planets the rotation of the earth uh for
example around the sun the moon around
the earth the earth and sun around the
galactic center the galaxy with motion
around the local group of clusters
center of mass
and we all know that the motion of
matter is caused by a central potential
an attractive force caused by the mass
or matter of that dynamical system and
as long as it's conservative as long as
it's not emitting energy emmy neuter and
her famous theorem in the 1900s
described a conservation law that all
conservation laws were associated with
symmetries so the conservation of
angular momentum results in the symmetry
the non-change of an object as it moves
in space
the conservation law conservation of
angular momentum is associated with
symmetry under rotation
so at the smallest scales too we know
that atoms are always in motion
before we even knew about atoms ludwig
boltzmann predicted that their motion
would result in the property that we
call temperature and also the property
of entropy which we've explored in many
videos on this channel
later albert einstein explained the
motion known as brownian motion with the
kinetic theory of molecules and
established for the first time that
molecules existed by the end of the 19th
century it was known that electrons
existed and it was even believed that
protons existed at the core of atoms as
shown by
rutherford and his famous plum pudding
model
and later bohr and others developed the
atomic hypothesis and the laws of atomic
motion and transitions where electrons
were kind of like a mini planetary
system we now know that that's wrong but
born nevertheless won a nobel prize for
that effort and the transitions between
different orbitals of principle quantum
number symbolized by the letter
lowercase n to higher levels and back
and forth and so forth were associated
with the emission or absorption of
quanta of light
quanta discovered and predicted by max
planck in the famous constant h bar h
that bears his name the quantum
revolution soon after revealed the
relationships between fundamental forces
of nature and their properties as they
extend throughout long or short ranges
so gravity acts over the largest
possible scales in the universe
governing the universe itself but it's
the weakest force by many many orders of
magnitude compared to electromagnetism
and the two nuclear forces the strong
nuclear force uh that is governing the
attraction and repulsion of atomic
nuclei and how they bind together the
weak nuclear force is responsible for
radioactive decay and fusion and fission
and the processes that keep our sun
illuminated so these were discovered
throughout the 30s 40s and 50s and it
was conjectured that these laws too in
quantum mechanics would also obey the
symmetry properties namely symmetry
under rotation of the classical
mechanical laws of planets and orbiting
uh stars etc in our universe but
physicists being careful observers and
careful never to trust their intuition
alone devised very precise experiments
in the 1950s at the national bureau of
standards in washington dc
the
first precision test of whether or not
you could have symmetries that we obey
believed to be obeyed in classical
mechanics whether or not those would
adhere and apply at the quantum level
those were proposed to be tested
and atom smashers cyclotrons and and
synchrotrons were developed smash them
together and a lot of conservation laws
were found to be sacrosanct in other
words conservation of linear momentum
conservation of energy and even
conjecture the existence of the neutrino
by wolfgang pauley in the 1930s was done
to save conservation of energy that's
how sacrosanct it was
now another law of nature is the
symmetry under mirror reflections the
fact that if you look at a pendulum
swinging back and forth in a mirror it
looks the same as if you look at it
directly without a mirror so that is a
property known as parity conservation
and if classical law is held at the
quantum level then the mirror image of a
physical system say a nucleus should
behave as the same exact way as its
direct image is looking at it directly
not in a mirror one such property would
be the spin or polarity of the emission
of
of the electron during the process known
as beta decay it was taken for granted
that the physics of elementary particles
would behave the same way as pendula but
was that true and in fact two physicists
frank yang and td lee in the night in
1955 and 56 worked on a proposal that
suggested perhaps physicists should look
more carefully they were theorists
nothing against theorists but they were
theorists and they conjectured that
perhaps the weak nuclear force
responsible for beta decay would not
obey the law of parity conservation
so cnn or frank yang and td tsunda lee
proposed that this should be looked
after
and one of their colleagues took up the
challenge
in fact she did so during her christmas
break
in the winter of 1956 and thanks to her
we received as physicist as
a scientist a wonderful present that we
could scarcely have imagined without her
work
so she decided to test the proposal and
she devised an ingenious experiment
involving an isotope of the element
cobalt which could be envisioned as a
spinning top spinning around and that
spinning top would then be polarized
magnetically polarized to point in one
direction and then it would decay
because it's subject to the weak nuclear
force and the weak nuclear force
features beta decay beta rays or
electrons they would shoot out in one
direction or another what she found is
that the direction of the emission did
not depend on whether or not you were
looking at this in a mirror or not
namely if you reverse the direction of
spin of the cobalt nucleus you still got
the same shoot-off direction of the beta
ray of the electron rays so she saw this
as a chance to make history and verify
the predictions of her colleagues xian
yang and td lee
[Music]
reading from uh my friend stefan
alexander's book
uh fear of a black universe past guest
on the into the impossible podcast
there is another symmetry between the
electron field and the photon that also
has to be violated it's called cp
violation for c for charge and p for
parity this symmetry is similar to a
mirror reflection when you look in the
mirror there's a spatial reflection that
inverts left and right your left hand
looks like your right hand under a
mirror reflection we can imagine the cp
inversion as a type of mirror that
reflects the charge and orientation of
the electron simultaneously
a spinning particle like the cobalt 60
nucleus under a cp inversion sees itself
looking like its antiparticle the
positron with its spin reversed
or an anti-cobalt 60 nucleus if you
could imagine such a thing so if we want
to create matter over antimatter this cp
symmetry would have to be violated and
he relates it to one of the so-called
sacrifice conditions that we'll talk
about in a future video wu's brilliant
experiment measured the directional
properties of beta decay in cobalt 60.
and this weak nuclear force was thought
originally to be parody symmetric
according to most physicists before lee
and yang but wu set out to prove if that
was really true her results turned
physics upside down or maybe flipped it
in a mirror a better way to think about
it
woo demonstrated that parody was not
conserved and the universe therefore has
a parody preference and an exact mirror
universe could not exist
her paper was published in 1956
and it was confirmed by others such as
leon letterman also at columbia
university and it took the field of
physics by storm leading to nobel prizes
but not for madame wu
unfortunately she was left out of the
1957 nobel prize and it did go to td lee
and xian yang
and they deserved it certainly but so
did she and in fact there was a slot in
open slot since the nobel committee
rules that arbitrary organization has a
rule that three people could win it even
though alfred nobel said only one person
could win it nevertheless they could
have given it to three people including
qin seung woo but she never won it
she's been called many many wonderful
accolades including the first lady of
physics the chides madame curie and many
other accolades she was just this year
2021 awarded a u.s postal service stamp
in her honor forever stamp which she
certainly deserves but many think she
lost out on the main prize that she did
deserve the nobel prize she never
fretted about it she never complained
about it and her storied career also
included work on the manhattan project
before this apocal 1956 experiment that
confirmed that our universe is more
twisted than we could have ever thought
only four women have ever won nobel
prizes marie curie
uc san diego's own maria gephardt mayor
andrea guezz in 2020 and donna
strickland in 2018.
women are still woefully
underrepresented as i talk about in my
book losing the nobel prize
and uh and continuing to do so
unfortunately to the detriment i think
of the history of physics if nothing
else
history is often taught in physics by
who won a nobel prize and i urge you to
look in any popular account of physics
how many times a nobel prize is
mentioned so and so won it for this
discovery etc etc so it's become sort of
the sacred count i've talked a lot about
that so not only is parity conservation
violated in physics sometimes it is in
the nobel awards as well and we have
other symmetries which may also appear
in the twisted arrangement of life
itself of the dna molecule as we
discussed in this video over here
why is dna twisted
and that may be a fundamental symmetry
or it may be a byproduct of life that
the universe on both the weak nuclear
force and the strong nuclear force
exhibits parity violation cp violation
and not this other violation that could
also be concomitant called cpt violation
we'll talk about that later
the question that is most delightful
perhaps to think about is whether or not
the entire universe could exhibit some
form of parody violation and concomitant
with that a form of what's known as
lorenz
violation and variance of the lorenz
transform which underpins all of modern
physics starting from special relativity
general relativity and far far beyond so
stay tuned for future videos about those
fascinating topics
for now leave a comment do you think
madame wu missed out on a nobel prize
that she deserved
make sure to like comment and subscribe
to this channel and hit the notification
bell so you never miss an episode i plan
to do many more of these 30 minute
thesis episodes including uh deep dives
into the essence of particle physics of
cosmology of experimental physics and
beyond and i'll also continue to provide
you with interviews in depth with the
greatest thinkers in all of science and
philosophy
even religion and even in leadership on
my tuesday deep dive interviews so for
now i thank you for going into the
impossible and stay tuned for more great
content
[Music]
if you like this video click here for a
discussion of cp violation and cosmology
with sean carroll or watch this video
with one of my scientist friends don't
forget to subscribe